how's it going guys my name is matt
you're watching my channel code tech
tutorials and today
or over maybe the next few days or
whatever it ends up taking we're going
to be coding up a little game from
scratch and this is sort of a follow
along example we're going to use c plus
plus and the intention here is basically
to help people understand syd attacks
the project organization how to put
things together and a little bit of
problem solving i would really count
this more in the
beginner to intermediate region but near
the end we might be getting a little
more complicated and to the advanced
expert or capstone region but we're
going to start out simple and we're
going to start out
with just uh
building from the ground up and this is
just one of those things where
if you're
rather new to coding or c plus plus it's
gonna
really maybe
help you understand some of the basic
concepts and some some troubleshooting
that some programmers might do
or some design decisions that
programmers might have so i recommend
follow along at c plus but really you
can use any language if you want to or
if you're just watching this for
entertainment that's cool too
so uh yeah let's get into it let's just
dive right into it so what we want to do
here is we want to make a little rpg we
just want to make like a classic rpg i'm
going to bring up a notepad
we're just going to make just a little a
little bit of a design
of uh what we kind of want to go for so
rpg kind of a classic style let's make
like a a warrior class
a
wizard class
or a caster let's make like a cleric or
healer
class
or maybe you call them support or
something
uh you know we'll stick to these really
core basics that are very common on
games and of course the thief class or
rogue thief never makes much sense
anyway it's like what do you got to
steal stuff
that's all your class does steal stuff
thief is a terrible class name you ask
me
but okay
so yeah we'll go with we'll go with this
so the warriors the typical heavy armor
wearing guy wizard of course being the
caster
set in a medieval world type thing and
what do we want to do with these guys so
let's think about this a little bit here
so i guess the main thing we want to do
here is we want to have a battle system
battle system and we're really just
going to make this all like just logic
and text to begin with but later when we
get more advanced we might put some
graphics on top of this logic to make it
like an actual real game that you could
play
and
we'll see we'll see i also
am kind of going to gauge this as we go
because uh who knows if this like series
absolutely tanks and no one's watching
it then
you know why continue kind of thing but
if it's doing well then sure
we'll do some awesome stuff with it
eventually and maybe even make it fully
blown fully grown
so i am going to say and i'm going to be
doing the same thing pause frequently
like any time you get stuck pause and
try to look up what you're stuck on just
i'm kind of interjecting in the middle
here i'm doing this in sort of a live
cast way
but i'm doing the same thing if i get
stuck i'm going to pause the recording
and figure out what i'm doing before i
continue at least most of the time maybe
not all the time i do want to do some
live thinking so that you can see like
kind of the thinking process some but
don't be afraid if you can't like keep
up with this non-paused
constantly going type video because it's
often very hard but hopefully this helps
and i know what a ton of people are
already going to say
just like watching this and watching
maybe the the bit of unpreparedness and
that's why didn't you wait till you're
more prepared well the reality is if you
wait till you're perfectly prepared
you'll never get anything done
so
you just gotta jump in and go for it and
do it and that's part of the point of
this too because like right now like my
throat is bothering me and i feel like
i'm going to cough or you know get
stuck and with phlegm any second and
it's like driving me crazy so i i don't
want to start but you know you got to do
it so if it happens it happens all right
so we want a battle system and to keep
it simple we're going to make it turn
based
and we also maybe want a few like levels
uh we don't want to worry about
networking pvp servers none of that we
might sell later that could be cool
because something like this could easily
turn into
something bigger but we don't want to
keep it super complicated so let's we'll
have some levels and that way we can
have like a beginning and an end and a
little bit of progression and we'll also
have like class levels with with these
guys and
uh we'll say world levels here
and we'll also do like uh class levels i
don't know where to write that i guess
over here
class levels
so we want to have like a level up
system
and some world levels with uh different
monsters
and of course
uh we're gonna have like uh abilities
right everyone's gonna have different
abilities and there's gonna be maybe a
few special things we're going to have
to decide what those are let's just come
up with a few basic ones like the
warrior for example is going to have uh
highest hit points
uh uses best armor
and this brings up another thing we're
also going to have equipment so we need
to put that in here somewhere uh we will
have equipment
and maybe their
equipment is going to be like
uh certainly certain people can use it
or like the rogue can only use it if he
gets a certain talent or something like
that we don't necessarily want to get it
that complicated
uh but
uh well yeah we'll keep it simple we
might not even get to equipment
for a long time because we might just
default to say hey you can level up this
and you have heavy armor or something
that would keep it really simple but the
point is really to understand learn
programming problem solving and all that
so i hope that all makes sense so
highest hit points uh we'll say like
oh what else would he have we'll just
stick with highest hit points for now
because the rogue might hit harder the
wizard might hit harder or something
it's not necessarily going to be the
highest damage
but we do want each class to have like a
strong point and maybe the weak point
like we could say okay let's say that is
maybe slow moving maybe yeah we'll just
stick with uh advantages no disadvantage
for for now uh uses magic
now that's an advantage right uses
support magic
and we'll say the rogue is the highest
uh consistent damage
consistent damage
because uh they don't necessarily have
to use uh like mana or something like
the like the wizard may and you know
we'll go with that okay that's fine
and
highest consistent oh well maybe even
melee and range damage yeah why not
melee ranged damage so we'll just come
we'll just start with these simple
things
and what else could we have here we
could have like a shop system that could
that could go in with the equipment shop
we could do a shop system
and we could also do like a consumable
system
like potions and sit and stuff like that
so all right i keep hitting savings
popping up the thing but we're not
oh yeah we'll save
uh
we'll call this rpg world thing for
ctt okay there we go
so we got all this to start
that's
that's our basic design so how with code
and
and the magic of computer power do you
turn this into a playable thing that can
run on your computer that you could ship
to your friends and say hey play my
little game i made that's that's like
the whole point of this isn't
the point is not for it to be good
it's just to get like a base
understanding
and that's the whole point of this
channel is to basically teach you some
basics so let's get into it i'm going to
drag this off to the side and we're
going to launch our thing of choice now
this is always a tricky subject i'd
recommend watching like my c
plus project structure crash course or
something like that because there are a
million different ways to do your
project and
i basically just get harassed in the
comments no matter what i tell you if i
say hey use this one because it's easy
then i get harassed by the some other
user that does it some other way it's
like no do it this way i don't care what
you use i'm gonna be honest i don't care
what you use they all work they're all
fine there's one that's terrible then
people will tell you use ming gw use ms
build use clang i i don't care all right
i am going to use uh visual studio you
know why because it's easy that's why i
don't have like a big elaborate reason
it's not better than this or that for
any particular thing it's easy that's
why it handles like everything for you i
don't have to go look up cmake in
commands i don't have to look up and
make files and figure out stuff sure i
can i've done it a million times but i
don't want to have to do it again
so i'm just going to pick something that
does it super easily so we're going to
use visual studio
20 22.
if you want to use something else cool
fair enough it's going to be just as
easy on anything i could literally do it
on whatever too it's fine
and you could even do it with python
java go whatever language you want
because the logics are going to be the
same
but the way you organize things and the
way the languages work is different so
i'd recommend c plus plus
if you're following along but
might even be more fun in javascript
because you could easily put an
interface
on
like a website or something but that's
totally up to you we're just going to go
to create a new project now when i
installed visual studio 2022 i did
install all the c plus plus
standard stuff
i don't remember exactly what it's
called but basically i just checked the
c plus plus
development so that's really all i did
nothing super special this is a free
program this is all free most of you
have windows if you don't you can do it
on linux if you're using linux i'm sure
you're bright enough to figure that out
and compile with gnu c plus plus
and then stuff like that that's fine if
you really need help join the discord if
you still need more help join the
patreon at like the support tier and
i'll help you that's fine
all right so we're going to start with
an empty project
empty console
project
sounds good
and we're just going to name this
demo rpg
no need to get more elaborate than that
that's all we're going to call it and we
get our stuff over here we're just going
to add
a new item let's get a source file it's
called source.cpp we're going to rename
it to main
and that's basically it gives us a
main.cpp we're going to include iostream
oh yeah also i guess i should mention
we're not going to use any libraries to
start out we might use some when we get
more advanced like when we're i guess if
we start adding sound and graphics and
stuff like that or any other special
stuff but sure we'll add in some
libraries but to start out to get like
this basic core game loop going you
don't need anything you can do it with
all the primitives
in the language so no need to get any
more advanced so we're just going to
make an ant name i'm sure you're
probably already familiar with this and
if you're not and uh
okay
it's just very basic c plus plus it's an
entry point for a piece of software this
is where your program starts of course
so we're going to try to say all the
basic stuff as we go
all right very good
now another just mention of the ways
we're going to do this okay let's go
over here and let's make this uh show
the folder structure by clicking show
all files might be a little different
for you but that's all we're going to do
because uh yeah this kind of arranges in
a way where you can add multiple
runnable solutions or
make little libraries and sub libraries
and stuff it's just just the way the
visual studio is you can do it manually
with
whatever you're using to or you can just
not do it at all and only
do one project if you're starting out
just keep it all in one project it's
gonna be a lot simpler that way
but you could in theory like make any of
these little parts of this their own
library or whatever like we could have a
shop system library and an equipment
library and stuff like that
so different terms for different things
when i'm saying library in this mode i
mean like c plus plus libraries but also
you could say like
you have like a dictionary of all the
different items or equipment and stuff
that's kind of a different thing i'll
probably call that more like a structure
or something
just a little odd overlap of terminology
there all right uh that i thought i'd
clarify for any of the total newbies out
there all right so let's let's just add
a few things to start out with uh if
we're gonna have
um
you know what let's even
let's even like make this off to the
side a little bit like like this so we
can just keep it in mind
all right so we need to think about a
few things maybe maybe we'll go ahead
and design some base class stuff today
and a few other things we'll kind of get
like some core stuff
set up and then we'll link it all
together a little more later
and uh not to be confused with
the c plus plus linking i just mean like
we're gonna like make it all kind of
work together in a flow so
i'll try to avoid overlapping the
terminology because you know like
linking libraries and c plus plus is a
whole different thing and that's not
what i meant there
uh we're going to try to avoid that like
i said we're not really going to use any
library so we're just going to stick to
the primitives all right so let's make
let's make our classes now all these
classes are going to have some things in
common for example they're all going to
have the hit points right they're all
going to have like some amount of hp and
they're all going to have
what else they're gonna have like an
attack they're gonna have uh
i don't know maybe a few other things
we'll think of something else but for
now we're just gonna stick with hit
points and maybe an attack
all right so we we can we could either
put these in their own file or we could
just like put them all above the main uh
either's really fine uh if we put them
in their own file
let me think here for a second yeah no
let's just let's put them up here for
now so
let's have like a a structure there's a
struct called
uh hp
and hp
uh we might even make this a class
actually
well yeah we'll make this a class
actually you know what let's just go
ahead and let's make this home file
because it's going to get confusing
after a while so we'll go new item
let's just do a header
and we're just going to call this hp.h
and that's it so then we'll take this
class that we started to build and copy
it in here we've got a private once at
the top so it doesn't double included
anywhere and we're just going to keep it
a plain old class we're going to have
public and we're going to have private
and we could also have protected because
i think we might be inheriting from this
uh but we'll see so uh privately we're
gonna have like and uh
and we'll just stick with integers for
the most part here
uh yeah that's gonna keep it simple uh
we'll have like a current
hp
and then we're going to have ant max hp
that way we can keep track of the hit
point bar i'm sure you guys are all
familiar with the good old hit point bar
and we're not going to get much more
complicated like than that we could do
something like uh shield we could have
like you know how
in games you often have a shield that
absorbs some stuff we're not going to do
that i don't think now
or we could do like temporary hp for
shield
uh why actually why not let's do it
let's go
let's go with temp hp
or shield or something yeah we'll call
it shield
field hp
then that's good enough for now now
ideally if you're going to be doing math
in these and like percents and stuff you
probably want these to actually be
floats or doubles but we're going to
stick with integers so that they round
nicely and if we have to do some math
we'll do it in our functions and then
we'll round to an integer and that that
should be fine and also it often doesn't
make sense for like your max hp to be
negative or zero so
maybe integer is not even the best
choice maybe like an unsigned int is
better or a
standard unt 32 underscore t
and of course we want to use that we
gotta include c standard mint
to get that that's just a 32-bit
unsigned integer and we could do a
similar thing here too we could go
standard
and 32t
uh that's assuming we're going to have
some pretty big pools of hit points
because like a 32-bit integer is huge so
if we really cared about space and we
were making this for like a calculator
or something maybe we'd make these a
little smaller
like a 16-bit or something
right and we probably want them all to
be the same type actually you know what
current hp
is is not going to neither do these can
ever really be zero so let's just start
with unsigned let's do all unsigned
because none of these ever want to be
negative right and we'll do some checks
to make sure they don't like go
into the negative because what happens
with an unsigned integer it goes
negative it actually ends up turning
into a giant positive
so uh you can look that up if you want
but basically it wraps around to the top
end so
uh
yeah i'll just leave it at that you can
look it up if you want to know more but
it's uh it's not too complicated so we
can look up the max size of this and
we'll do some googling on the fly here
because this is what programmers do
let's see so brought up a window and
we'll go uh
max size
of a un 30 or un16
and uh and it looks like it's
65
or this hex decimal we're not really
going to get to do into the hexadecimal
stuff but it's basically
uh as you can see here it's four bytes
and this would be the max size
uh the 32 bit one is eight bytes so we
could get more precision but in our
small game i don't think we're going to
be getting we know we're not going to
deal with giant hit points
because like the max damage is not going
to be anywhere close to that i don't
think starting out now another thing we
could do and we'll just get right into
this
since uh since it's part of
the thing is we could we could do some
kind of type def
so if we want to change these later we
don't have to change them throughout the
entire program we just change them in
one place so let's go ahead and do that
actually let's just add another header
file
and we'll call this like uh
like hit point types sure
doesn't really matter dot h fine uh and
we'll just uh
this one we will include the c standard
ant dot h
or whatever it was let's just see
standard end
yeah let's get the dot h off there don't
need it all right uh yours may depending
on what you're using
oh linux might be a little different uh
stuff like that but
uh we'll just do a type def
and we'll say
that uh
how does typedef work i always forget
the order of these always forget which
one you put first so you just we just
google search uh type def c plus plus
very good and then we'll find some info
on it
simple enough now you don't really want
to look at there's going to be like a
bunch of blog articles and just like
just people with their own little
versions of things
i would recommend not looking at those
if you can avoid it because you'll get
conflicting information sometimes people
will make a blog article and they'll be
like using some specific thing and
they'll say what's right for them but
it's not going to be right for every os
so usually you want to look at the
actual reference which is this website
right here uh this this is going to be
like the actual specification
uh in general so you
correct me if i'm wrong on that it's
it's generally what i use so
what you do is you do a typedef
let's see okay there's an ill-formed one
just learn about real quick here there's
a simple typedef that's probably all
we're going to use so you
declare typedef
the type and then what you want to call
it so this will be our specific name
so
we're going to be using standard
un16t right
underscore t
and we're going to call this
uh i guess hp type
for now so now the point of this is
going to be if we ever want to change
this type we don't have to go in all
over our program and change these we can
just change it in one spot and this way
we can just use hp type for here
there we go and we don't actually have
to include c standard end anymore we're
just going to include
with double quotes our hit point types
dot h
okay
and that should rectify itself
shortly did i spell oh it's got two t's
okay so yeah i'm just kind of winging
the names and there we go it seems
pretty happy this hp type resolves to uh
unt 16 t
and if we decide later we want these to
be something else we just change it here
and changes throughout the program
pretty common thing you see in programs
is stuff like this just to help simplify
it alright so there we go we got that so
those are private we're not going to be
able to access them
so what we want to do here is
uh like uh
we want to make a few functions that
modify these and modify them correctly
because if we're
losing or gaining hit points in any
particular situation we don't want it to
mess up because we wanted to check if
there's a shield first reduced from the
shield if we're out of shield
or whatever maybe there's some special
abilities that we ignore shield
we're not going to deal with that that's
too complicated for this particular
thing but you get the point so we want
functions
that modify these private variables our
case and you don't have to do this you
could it's just going to be a lot
messier and a lot more error prone if
you don't do it this way because what if
you have something that does more damage
than your current hp and then it takes
it negative but since it's negative and
it's an unsigned in it wraps around to a
huge positive and then suddenly because
you took too much damage your current hp
is like a gazillion but your max hp is
only 10 and you're like what the heck my
program's crashing my current hp is a
million my my character's hitting for
nine nine nine nine nine when he's
supposed to only be hitting for four you
know there's going to be all kinds of
weird stuff if you mess this up is the
point so you want to have functions to
kind of like control what's happening
here
and then that's the point this is where
some logic comes where you comes in
where you got to think about things you
got to think about how the types work
and make it basically error proof the
best you can you want to make it so that
like no matter what happens in your
program it's not going to cause anything
strange to happen it'll resolve
correctly and uh the player playing the
game is not he's not going to have that
moment for like
they say then you've probably done this
if you've played any game ever because
it always happens in games they're
always really glitchy
you're not going to have people going
wtf devs do you have a brain and stuff
like that you know we just want it to
work correctly and we want people to
have a good experience right that's the
whole point here so let's make like a a
thing to set your max hp void
set
max hp
and it's going to take
an hp type
and it's going to what is called new max
hp
and obviously it can't be zero right if
your h max hp is zero then that that
just doesn't work so we'll say if a new
uh max hp
max hb is uh less than one
then what i don't know
we'll return i guess it's not
necessarily a great case because it will
get ignored and uh we probably want like
some kind of error case here actually uh
so maybe we'll think about that we'll
come back to that but return isn't
necessarily the best thing maybe we want
to return like a true or false here so a
bull uh for success and we can comment
returns
uh true if set success
fully
all right so in this one we would say
return false because it said that's just
an example of something you could do
that's that's fine
there could be other stuff you could
return the new max hp
and maybe if it's zero then you know its
problem there's other ways you can
handle is the point but this should be
fine for now and it will allow us to
write a little error checking later in
our codes but otherwise if it's not zero
which uh if it's anything that's not
less than one it's not zero because it's
an unsigned
integer
uh it's going to be fine so we'll just
say max hp
equals
current to hp
and now let's think about some other
scenarios so what if you change your max
hp
and now your current hp is like higher
or wait i typed this wrong max hp equals
new max hp right um
so what if now
maybe you set this and your current hp
is now off and doesn't work
uh so we just have to account for that
we'll just make a little if statement if
uh current hp is greater than max hp
then we'll just say current hp equals
max hp
so
that way it just equals it but if it's
already less than the max then it's not
going to increase it's just going to
stay the same so that just that should
handle most the cases there and boom we
got a nice little set max hp function it
should work pretty good there and if it
gets to the bottom here we'll just
return true because it's successful
and very good
so the only true error case here or no a
weird way of wording it the only error
case here is
if they try to set it to zero that's
just not allowed
uh so yeah very good fair enough that's
that's mine for now and yes we're
writing this in a header file uh we're
gonna build everything as just a single
object with this main for now we might
change that later but that's why i'm
building everything in header files
because i'm just going to include it all
in the main
but
this particular thing is probably going
to get included
or
used for these classes later so we're
basically going to be building these
classes for a little while and once
those are all done we'll move on to the
other systems
all right so let's continue let's write
a few more things now we just want to
write some other things to handle all
these other things so what if we have
let's have another one a bull uh like a
take damage
we could do a take damage
uh
hp type
uh damage
so just be amount of damage and this
will basically be a subtract operation
pretty straightforward here they could
take zero damage that'd be fine no
problems there do we really need a bull
here not necessarily we could probably
stick with void i don't think we need to
return anything in this case
um
if they take let's say
so we'll just go current hp
or maybe we'll do a quick check here
like if
damage
damage is greater than
current hp
then we'll just set current hp to zero
because we don't want him to go negative
that's gonna like mess stuff up in our
our theory i mean maybe in your game you
want people to go negative because like
in dungeons and dragons for example you
can go negative and hit points you just
uh you're actually still alive at zero
you're still alive at negative five you
die when you get below what negative ten
i don't know the rules may have changed
a little bit i haven't played in a bit
but so some games allow for negative
we're not going to allow for negative
debt is zero
there's no other case or well maybe
we'll say unconscious because maybe
we'll have some revive thing that claire
can do or something but we're gonna keep
it simple we don't want it to be like
hardcore mode where you die forever
we're just gonna say you're like
unconscious or something
um well we'll figure more out later if
we need to uh we'll just say hp equals
zero so if the damage they're taking is
more than their current hp we'll just
set their hp to zero don't really need
to do any further calculating
so in that case we would just return
afterwards and now since we got more
than one line in its if statement uh we
cannot we're going to need some brackets
here but all this return does is is say
exit from the function
uh yeah i guess i am assuming some c
plus plus knowledge here
uh
maybe i should have said that earlier
but
if i go over every little thing this
will go on for literally ages so it's
just not possible
i have some tutorials on beginner c plus
plus if you want to see those and
there's a lot of beginner stuff out
there so
uh yeah you're going to need some to
know those basics of course language
you're doing it
and otherwise okay so if we didn't
return there we're just going to go
current hp
minus equals
damage
and that should be it we shouldn't need
to do anything further we could do a
check here to see if there's zero but
we'll do that somewhere else no worries
because we don't have like a boolean for
alive or dead or unconscious or anything
like that this is just a plain hp pull
with some functions to handle it and
let's write a few more and then we're
going to get out of here
so we just need one for like uh maybe
heal so avoid
uh heal
and once again we will take
an hp type
of uh
mount we'll just call this one a mount
we need it to all be called a mount
not too sure but we could say
that uh
yeah let's do some simple checks here
we'll say if amount
plus
current hp
is greater
do i have insert press or yeah i don't
know okay
if the amount plus the current hp is
greater than max hp
then
we're just going to set it to max
all right because we don't we don't you
can't overheal we're not going to allow
overhealing some gains low overhealing
maybe you have special ability where it
says if you overheal you get a little
shield or something we're not going to
do that right now if we need to we can
and for that sort of stuff what you
basically want to do is make this
so that it is virtual and that you can
override it but we'll worry about that
later because maybe we'll give a priest
some mobility like that or something
like that or maybe the warrior will have
an ability that says hey you can
overheal a little bit and you get a
shield but
that could be something cool and that
might be cool for teaching a concept
later so we'll we'll come back to that
one
all right so we'll just say current hp
equals max hp that's what i was typing
here
very
good otherwise
uh okay and if that happens that case
happens we just want to return
uh and if that case doesn't happen
then we're just going to go
uh current
hp plus equals amount
we already know that's not greater than
the max hp because we did that check
right here so this should be fine
now i'm writing these functions off the
top of my head with some quick logic
that i'm just coming up with like right
now so it's very very possible that i am
um
introducing some error cases these might
not be perfect and for that what we
probably want to do is write some test
functions now a test function would
basically be something we run in our
main
or uh something or if we make these
their own standalone library and we have
a set of tests that go with them to say
hey let's make sure the hp stuff is all
working correctly run the set of tests
for every scenario possible
we could get into that i guess let me
know if you want to we could do like a
test thing but test take a long time to
write and i think just me saying that
might give you a gist of how it goes
but uh we're not gonna do that for now
we're just gonna we're just gonna skip
over that whole testing thing but
actually it's a good idea to test if
you're doing a real project because of
that stuff i just said
so i think that covers the most of it we
could let's make a shield let's say uh
void uh set shield
oh you know what uh before we do the
shield let's consider this take damage
uh
plush shield
all right because actually we want
the shield to uh
be calculated in this damage we want the
damage to be taken off the shield first
so current hp is minus equal the damage
well we could do it with the shield
first we could go
uh
yeah shield hp
minus equals damage
uh if
shield is yeah we're gonna have a little
special logic here for the shield you
know what actually let's forget the
shield shield's making it too
complicated let's just leave the shield
off so we're just going to delete all
the shield block let's keep it plain old
hp
uh throwing a shield in there yeah we
could do it it's just gonna take a lot
longer it's going to make a lot more
complicated of logic
for this taking damage because we're
going to have to calculate and do they
have a shield how much of a shield take
that amount of damage
off of how much damage they're taking
and reduce the shield or reduce just the
shield a little bit and then return you
know it's going to be a lot of
additional cases and this function would
just grow to like this big basically uh
probably so
that maybe there's a really simple way
of writing it that i'm not thinking of
if you can think of it awesome i am
going to make this repo public at some
point i have no idea where it's going to
be at the time of these video releases
but
there we go i think this is good enough
for an hp pull uh yep looks good
so we got a set max hp take damage heal
yeah i think that's all we really need
uh so yeah we can just uh
we also want some getters and setters
that's i well we got kind of setters
it's these right here
but uh we and you're just going to have
to heal the set current hp i think
so
because you could just heal for like a
huge amount and it will set you to the
max all the time basically but we want a
way to for the user to get the hp and
get the
current hp and the max hp because these
are private you're not going to be able
to access them unless you make a friend
a class of like uh friend class and then
we'll have all these different classes
for your wizard or whatever so we don't
want to do that we're just going to go
uh hp type
get
max hb
and then we'll just return
whatever it currently is
that way we have a public access version
we might change how this works later uh
so there's that
uh yeah let's actually put it up here by
the setter
okay cool
and we could do the same thing
for the other one get current hp
it might be better for these to be like
protected so that whatever inherits from
this would work but
we haven't fully decided how we're going
to use these yet for our
warrior wizard cleric rogue so we'll
start building those in next episode
because this one's getting a little long
a little longer than i intended but
we've got
like kind of the core design
uh worked out and we know some stuff to
build so we can just continue to type
away and chug away until it's going so
that's kind of where i wanted to to get
with the starting episode and i of
course you know what current hp is there
current hp
i'll tell you what actually you know
what i'm just going to release this as
is like immediately i'll put this repo
up and if you guys want to
hack on this and make any little tiny
improvements awesome uh but uh i'll come
out with the next one as soon as i can
and if i can get your updates in there
cool if not sorry
but uh i'm gonna try to keep it rolling
as quickly as possible try to release
these every day until we get to a sweet
point
or i get so burnt out that i can't take
it anymore or you guys harass me for
something so badly in the comments that
i just give up and quit youtube
altogether we'll see what happens first
you can support me on patreon you can
hit the join button down below
and uh yeah don't forget to hit like on
this video share it if you know a new
coder that wants to go along with stuff
and learn some basics and and get going
with a little project like this
and uh yeah we'll see you guys in the
next one link down below for all the
stuff i mentioned probably unless i
forget to leave a link
alright
peace out